on March 28 2020 the governor of New
York announced that he was delaying his
state's April election I don't think
it's wise he'd be bringing a lot of
people to one location 18 other states
had already delayed or modified their
spring elections it would endanger
public health to allow thousands of
people to assemble but the state of
Wisconsin made a different call the only
state to move ahead with its election
polls if you can believe it are open in
Wisconsin this morning on April 7th
voters in Wisconsin got in line waited
for hours standing six feet apart
wearing mass with some poll workers in
full protective gear one voter made a
sign that seemed to sum up the situation
perfectly people are calling it the
photo of the year quote this is
ridiculous I'm sitting with my card in
my lap I was like this whole thing is
just ridiculous the people who are
supposed to be making sure things are
safe for us like I felt like they kind
of threw us under the wagon you know the
next day the Governor of New Jersey
announced they were postponing their
election to I don't want a Wisconsin
where folks had to pick between
exercising their right to vote on the
one hand and protecting their own
personal health Wisconsin's election
highlights something that the u.s.
really needs to figure out soon in
November there's an election to decide
the next president but it's highly
unlikely that Kovan 19 will be over and
done with by them we might even be
dealing with a second wave of it so if
public gatherings are a health risk how
are you supposed to have an election
I am coming to you from the Robert's
family voting booth here my dining room
table this is Dave he's at home in
Seattle Washington Dave's done a lot of
reporting on what he says is a simple
solution to how America can vote during
the pandemic every election and it's fun
Washington is one of the few states that
runs its entire election through the
mail I think I've been voting voting by
mail basically works by taking two
important elements of Odie's verifying
your identity and filling out the ballot
and moving them from a polling place to
your home where the ballot gets mailed a
few weeks before the election and that
has two really obvious benefits first
you have literally weeks to do as much
research as you want so when you fill
that circle you're like I'm friggin
voting I'm capital D voting right now
and second voting by mail takes away a
lot of the common reasons people don't
vote being forced to take a day off work
fine I want to watch the kids you take
your kids with you and go to a crowded
balloting place hope that your name
hasn't been struck from some role for
some random reason wait four hours three
hours five hours inline voting by mail
clears those hurdles and the effects are
really easy to see in 2018 a County in
western Nebraska got permission from the
state to run their entire election by
mail every voter there got a mail-in
ballot while voters in the rest of the
state voted the old-fashioned way across
Nebraska voter turnout was 24% but in
that one County it was important double
that turns out that making it easier to
vote means more people vote on average
states with all-male voting systems have
a higher turnout than other states a
poll from April 2020 find that Americans
would overwhelmingly be in favor of
holding the next presidential election
entirely by mail but that still leaves a
chunk who aren't sold on it one reason
is fraud the possibility that your vote
might be more likely to get lost stolen
or coerced if you vote at home
so I asked an expert on voting by mail
how serious and common Orestes is it's
exceedingly rare
so I also asked someone who runs
elections no widespread or systematic
voter fraud I asked a political
scientist use an expert on election data
it's highly unlikely anyone's gonna
steal your vote an election law expert
concerns about voter fraud or way over
Heights and an expert on voting rights
you are still more likely to be struck
by lightning than to find mail ballot
fraud the reason vote by mail fraud is
rare is that even though in theory it's
possible it's not very effective it
helps to think in terms of wholesale
fraud versus retail fraud election
security experts worry about wholesale
fraud lots and lots of votes being
tampered with at once people are voting
on machine you just have to have the one
machine with one point of contact there
are a lot less worried about what they
call retail fraud votes that get
tampered with one at a time that someone
could come by and seal your ballot fill
it out
but even if that does happen vote by
mail systems typically give you a way to
track your vote and make sure it's been
counted you can track you about like an
Amazon package does not get much more
secure than that you can actually go in
our system and track it from when they
receive it when they verify the
signature and when it's ready to count
if they haven't returned that ballot I
guarantee you that the voter picks up
the phone and causes election officials
the checks and balances that are invoked
by mail in California there are stronger
and stricter guidelines on processing
vote by mail than there are in person
burgers to me it's a much more secure
process the same week that Wisconsin
held its election the state of Georgia
sent all its voters forms that would let
them request a mail ballot but Georgia's
Speaker of the House complained he said
voting by mail benefits Democrats this
will be extremely devastating to two
Republicans and
service in Georgia but there's no
evidence that voting by mail is better
for either party a study at Stanford
found that it doesn't get either party a
bigger share of either turnout or the
vote itself all it does is increase the
number of people who vote we haven't
seen any any benefit to one party over
another there's nothing political about
voting and and more people voting is a
good thing providing that all
vote-by-mail experience didn't change
those dynamics people were still voting
the way they wanted to vote I'm pretty
sure I'm living proof that you can elect
a Republican in a blue state and you can
do it in a vote-by-mail environment
every state in the u.s. already has some
kind of vote-by-mail option it's called
an absentee ballot but some states will
only give you one if you have a good
excuse
like if you're out of town or in the
military other states offer a no excuse
absentee ballot where you don't need to
give a reason but you still have to
request it voting by mail is something
every state already allows but very few
states are actually prepared to do an
entire election through the mail that's
what caused the problem in Wisconsin in
2016 about 250,000 Wisconsin voters
requested an absentee ballot in 2020
about five times that number requested
absentee ballots Wisconsin hadn't
prepared for that so a lot of people
never got their ballots and had to go
vote in person instead I was one of over
55,000 people who had requested an
absentee ballot who had not yet received
it I am desperately hoping that we can
make that an exclusive option if we're
still dealing with unsafe situations in
November it would not be that difficult
to ramp that up in time for the election
I mean you need to start now it's not
trivial but it's very doable in the five
states that have all-male voting there's
still an option to vote in person a back
up mostly for people who didn't get a
ballot or weren't registered to vote in
time but in most places voting by mail
is the back up and if lots of voters
feel that voting in person isn't safe a
backup won't be good enough
preparing election systems for that will
take time and right now there is time
but only if we start now
[Music]